[Music]
and even though many new year's eve
events have been canceled this year
clark county officials are still making
plans to make sure everyone remains safe
that night
thanks so much for being with us here at
noon everyone i'm alex backus
metro police just held a press
conference moments ago to remind
everyone about safety protocols
officers are taking extra precautions
and conducting
extra thorough safety sweeps in light of
the christmas day bombing in nashville
tennessee
authorities are also reminding everyone
that the governor's mask mandate
it is still in effect and to practice
social distancing
during any celebrations what we ask
what i ask on behalf of lvmpd is that if
you're coming to visit here
if you live here and you're coming to
the strip or downtown please be mindful
of these rules that are in place please
wear your mask
please try to social distance we want
you to have a good time we welcome you
to have a good time but we also don't
want to send ourself back
months in this pandemic things will look
different of course this year
metro is anticipating a smaller crowd
but will still have more than a thousand
officers on duty
that evening no glass large bags baby
strollers or
carts will be allowed on the strip